do I need to slate I have to sleep
because I'm Nikki from Fandango so what
is the obvious and you do the Fandango
can you do the Fandango is my question
actually Joe is to us what the Fandango
is well this is this is a well-known
fact that it's just a different
iteration of the Macarena it's just
basically that in Reverse you start from
the head and you end up on the hips and
you come out you know on the count of
three one two three go different dances
by our movement coaches actually yeah
like Paulie and Liam taught us many
different dance let's go let's do it
I'm the worst dancer I'm the worst
dancer I'd be like okay moving on okay
so um better to be a rock star because I
would think as an actor a lot of your
performance especially in film has to be
small it has to be contained you're on a
set nobody's talking and then you go and
you do something like this where you
have to be like big and loud cooler to
be a rock star or cooler to be an actor
do you think nothing actor because you
can do all the other things you can be
yeah you can be a baseball player you
can you can be all the dreams that you
had as a kid as an actor so I sort of
feel like that's maybe a little better
cuz you can do and what are you gonna
say what are you gonna say no I'm rock
star and the in the vein of like David
Bowie who got to be an MP in the film
the labyrinth as well can do both you
can't do both but what did you have more
what what was your Pratt like what do
you think I have to say just being on
stage and getting to perform in the
style of Freddie Mercury are some of the
most fun coolest things you could ever
do as a human being I'm gonna just put
that out there it is the most fun I
ever had performing was we're doing the
concert scenes you know it was cool
though is that like even though like the
extras were there for us they were
really excited when we came out on stage
like we would come out one by one and
they were like cheer for us and like be
like it's just like the weirdest like
that was awesome
one moment that I actually cried out
watching this morning was when you're
sort of meeting with the band for the
first time and they sort of make fun of
your incisors and you say I was born
with four extra incisors but then you
sort of like turn it around and turn it
on them have you guys did you have
anything you overcame or like something
that stood out that maybe when you first
started acting people said that'll never
work and now it's kind of like you're
that's your like thing I grew up in
Bellingham I mean that's to overcome
look I I mean I think it's fabulous that
I am the guy that got chosen to play
Freddie Mercury and I don't know that
that would have happened ten years ago
so I just can put it from that
perspective I think that's a that's a
significant change in the way Hollywood
work yeah I was an actor as a child as
well so I went everywhere my life no I
went through a very awkward phase as
children do and so that transition was
sort of something where you definitely
had to like I don't know you know
reintroduce yourself into this industry
even though you've been acting for ten
years or whatever you sort of have to be
like no I can still do this so that was
sort of a thing to overcome I guess what
advice can you give to Lucy about you'll
just never make them this business
Thanks
you